who would you want to go to dinner with
visually if I picked somebody just with
all the stories he's had from playing
for so long
um and just playing against people from
different Generations so he definitely
has some of those stories and that would
make for the most uh interesting person
to eat dinner with okay let's see what
is she because she's extremely
interested in person I mean he's
extremely experienced in life and
running chairs a very very nice person
to chat with I guess Vichy because he's
very educated and he's always a pleasure
to talk to you can learn from him
[Music]
punish at least I don't have to talk I
just turn him on and I sit back and
chill
I'll say Magnus I wanna be there in this
awkward silence and just watch him
suffer
what the hell am I doing here I'm gonna
watch him and make him suffer I feel
like I think we're done I'm like no I
think let's have some coffee or tea or
you want some dessert no but no I do
want some dessert they have excellent
cheesecake in this place did you know
that and then afterwards I'd be like had
a tea if you know
dinner felt like it was hours ago let's
just start all over and you know I think
we're gonna take a while there yeah
[Music]
okay
it's fantastic you can brush my hair and
take you anywhere
imagination life is your creation come
on baby let's go party